20 22 شرفت على النهايه كل عام وانتم بخير
وسنه جديده افضل واجمل علينا جميعا يا رب
وفي حلقتنا اليوم رح نستعرض معاكم ملخص
اللي غطيناه سوا على مدار السنه وفي موضوع
معين يعني السيطر اكثر من اي شيء ثاني
وقصته كلها بدات بجمله واحده قلتها في
ابريل
المصري
جزء لا يتجزء من عناويننا
يعني وبكل المجالات سياسه اقتصاد
تكنولوجيا اجتماع حقيقه كله هذا ملخص سريع
للي عمله ماسك في العالم وفي تويتر وفينا
في 20 22
الخبر الابرز والاهم وعلى كل الاصعد اليوم
هو شراء الى ماسك لتويتر وقال انه بيتمنى
انه يقلد اعدائه يبقوا على تويتر وخطط
ماسك مليئه بارقام مليونيه من حيث
المستخدمين وملياريه بالنسبه للارباح
وبشرنا وبشر ترامب بانه يقدر يرجع اخيرا
لتويتر انه علق صفقات تويتر طالب فيه من
تويتر انه تثبت له انه عدد حسابات او
الحسابات الوهميه اقل من 5%
بالتلاعب بسعر اسهم الشركه ويطالب في
بحقوقه فهو اشتكى ان الشركه رفض الطلبات
للكشف عن نسبه الحسابات المزيفه شركه
العطور ردت عليه باختصار انه الصفقات
هتكمل وهتتنفذ بالسعر والشروط المتفق
عليها عموما المعركه واضح انها محتدمه
لانه الطرفين بيحاولوا توجيهي القضيه وفق
جدول زمني
اللي في تماما عن ما يريد الاخر في الدرس
سجل انتصار على الماسك من الجوله الاولى
في التقادم في عز ما هو في دوامه قضيه مع
تويتر اتفجرت فضيحه عاطفيه دسمه والكلام
المتداول انه ماسك سرق زوجته واحد من اعز
اصدقائه عموما ماسك انكر كل الكلام اللي
جاء فيه التقرير ماسكه من بعد فضيحه تويتر
اللي فجرها مسؤول الامن السابق استفاد
اكيد من اللي صار واعلن انه راح يستدعي
المسؤول في تويز الشهاده في قضيه ومع
تويتر خلاص الجمعه راح تتم الصفقه صفقه
تويتر واهل الماسك لتصدره العناوين
والاخبار لشهور اخيرا تمت واهل خلاص سيد
تويتر الجديد بعد ما صار رئيس مو قادرين
نلحق علاج
تصريحات تغيرات ردود حل مجلس اداره تويتر
وعيان نفسه الرئيس التنفيذي للشركه ناوي
ماسك يترحل لكل مقابل ثمانيه دولارات
شهريا مو عشرين مثل ما اول اتنشر ما زال
مصر على رايه وبيرد شخصيا على الشكاوى
والاعتراضات فالقرار دخل حيز التنفيذ في
التحديث الجديد لنظام ايوس في ناس جلسه
بتترقب نشره اخبار الماسك اليوميه طلع
ماسك ابرر اوضح ان هو طول عمره مستقل ما
بيتبعل للجمهوريين ولا الديمقراطين ويعني
صداع العلامه الزرقاء مستمر يعني قال انه
تويتر راح يعمل كثير من الحماقات الاشهر
المقبله حساب ترامب عاد الى تويتر اليوم
الاثنين ماسك راح يسرح مجموعه جديده من
الموظفين لسلسله تغريدات القرار استعرض
فيها انجازاته في تويتر في الكم اسبوع
اللي فاتته استخدم كاس العالم اليوم في
حلقه جديده ضمن حلقات مسلسل التابعي قال
لهم انا الامير والكل بحاجه الاخبار اللي
احنا بنعرض لكم هي يا دوب خلاصه ابرز ما
يتعلق فيه وتويتر لانه فعليا مج التصريحات
ولتغريدات ولا تغييرات في الشركه من يوم
ما استلمها باعلن اني راح يطلق الشكل
الجديد لميزه التوثيق يوم الجمعه واللي
راح تعتمد الالوان الذهبي للحكومات
والرمادي للشركات والازرق والافراد ماسك
خلاص اعلن الحرب على ابل رسميا كشف انه
التقى رئيس ابل وحلوا سواء
سوء التفاهم اللي كان صاير بينهم ماسك قال
انه اي حساب بينشر معلومات عن الموقع
الحالي اي شخص راح يتم حظر نشر استطلاع
للراي طلب من متابعينه ويصوتوا على انه
يبقى في تويتر رئيس
وقال ان هو ملتزم بالنتائج الاستطلاع عليه
الا لما نلاقي شخص احمق كفايه علشان يستلم
رئاسه تويتر بداله
طيب مشاهدينا اللي شفتهم ملخص